hello everyone
my name is devendra kapadia and i am the
manager of calculus and
algebra at wolfram and
it's a great pleasure to talk to you
about
what's doing calculus and algebra today
so uh we are part of the very
traditional area of mathematica
calculus and algebra and of course we've
already been popular but
i'm happy to report that in fact thanks
to the work of our excellent team
we have lots of uh new features which
are being put into version 12.2 which is
just about to
come up now so i'm going to give a broad
overview of this functionality
no technical details just a little bit
of
overview and some simple examples so let
me begin by giving you
a an overview of the talk
so in this talk let's discuss the
following areas
so we have uh the new function
properties which is kind of
uh a lead feature for 12.2 a given a
function can assure it's injective
subjective bijective etc
then we have special functions under
which we have
improved elliptic functions we have the
new lamia functions
and the harmonic functions
and then under calculus
we have greatly improved laplace and
inverse laplace transform functionality
we have lots of improvements for
ordinary and partial differential
equations
with d solve and we have asymptotic
statistics for the first time just a
little bit of asymptotics and stats
combined um to show the power of our
system
both for asymptotics and statistics
and then from there on uh i'll talk
about a little bit about equation
solving
uh solve now assumption that's a very
important thing for everyone to know
and then the very last part i'll move on
to documentation
uh how things are being moved in that
area how we are trying to
make things more useful for everyone and
the new courses
uh current and planned and so hopefully
all that together will give you a good
picture of where we're heading
uh in the next year or so and of course
the end of the talk i'll also tell you
what
else we have today on on the plate for
you to go and enjoy
so let me begin with uh function
properties
so when you first learn functions at
middle school or wherever
uh you think of a function as being
defined from a set a to a set b in this
case a subjective function
and it's purely set theoretical so
you've got two ovals
nothing more and so you can talk about
set theoretical properties like
bijective
injectors etc but then a little later
you go to ninth or tenth grade
and then you say oh that first set on
the left was actually the x
axis and second set was the y axis and
on the y x and x axis you actually can
talk about topology you've got a notion
of continuity
you have calculus to do analytically and
you have
an order so you can talk about positive
negative
etc so that explains our
function properties function so we have
the set theoretical properties
we have new functions function injective
function subjective
and function bijective which will do
that for you
and then we have the topological and
analytic properties
and over there we have things like
function discontinuities
we have function singularities very
useful to actually find the
singularities and discontinue the
functions
functionality and analytic and then
you've got function miramorphic
so they're slightly more advanced but
still useful to quite a lot of people
and finally we have the sine properties
so you can ask
is the function positive is the function
negative is it monotonic
is it convex so together you can take
your favorite function
and give it the system and it will go
ahead and do a great job of telling you
exactly what the function has in terms
of properties
so just to give an example which you
might even find in a standard calculus
analysis textbook
so here's a function h of x
it is continuous because at zero but the
only problem is
you can actually let's say put one over
x equal to t
and then notice that sine is just
oscillating uh between minus one one
so this function certainly is continuous
uh
because function continuous says that uh
on the other hand
the first derivative h prime is not
continuous
so you got a function with a
discontinuous first derivative
and hence it is not analytic
so we can then go ahead and visualize
the
function in its first derivative there
you are
okay so uh clearly the function itself
is quite nice
but the derivative is terribly badly
behaved near
the origin so that's the key to
understanding
the function that don't have analyticity
okay on to the next function which i
think is worth knowing about
functional gravity is a very powerful
function it can compute the
singularities of literally any function
that you want
real or complex so just a simple
function arc tangent of p
square and what you see over here is
that
this function has actually nothing on
the real axis talk about
there are no singularities functions
that it says false there are no singular
at all
and if you plot it it looks nice and
smooth so that's a really boring
function on the
real axis but then
as soon as you move to the complex
domain
things change dramatically and you get
lots
and lots of singularities so here you
are that's the functionality result
it's huge so you say okay reduce can
help me please and it does
and what you see over here is that in
fact in this beautiful picture which i
showed in on the cover slide
the title slide for today uh you stay
off the real axis
you stay outside the circle but then
along these four lines over here
you act for these four rays you actually
have the singularities
so functionality is a wonderful way to
figure out
what exactly the singularities of your
function are and i'm sure it's going to
be used
widely both inside the system and
outside
okay so now having understood uh what
singularities are and why they're so
important and why real versus complex so
important
i can then talk about elliptic functions
so we have always had these elliptic
function system
uh in fact the particular variety i'm
talking about are called jacobian
elliptic functions
and there are 12 of them the jacobi sn
ecobee cn etc
and then of course there are 12 inverses
so together you have 24 of these
functions and the question is why are
there 12 of them
what does the sn mean this looks like
sine that looks like cosine
how are they related etc so let's see
how all that
relates to what we know okay so
on the real line on the real line in
fact these functions are
periodic analytics so here's your cobie
sn of x called one third
and in fact if i replace the one third
by a zero
then it would be exactly the sine
function so these elliptic functions
are very close related to the
trigonometric functions and in fact
they're used to
describe oscillations non-linear
oscillations
now when you go to the complex plane
then things change dramatically
so here is the same set of functions
but now you have uh the
you know a completely different behavior
because what happens that these ecobee
functions
are actually quotients of what are
called theta functions theta 1 theta 2
theta 3 theta 4 and because there are
four functions
you can divide them in different ways so
4 p 2 is 12
so there are 12 jacobi elliptic
functions
now these theta functions uh first of
all they're analytic
and secondly they are quasi doubly
periodic so
they're almost doubly periodic but not
quite but when you divide them
the bad things go away and you get this
double periodic
behavior for the elliptic function the
complex plane so you get this beautiful
tiling of the plane
uh and the question is why are the holes
over there well that's because
you're dividing by uh theta functions so
the singularities come from the zeros of
the denominator
theta functions so that's a quick
introduction to
elliptic functions and the question is
why am i talking about them now in 12.2
we had them forever
well in 12.2 what we've done is to make
dramatic improvements
for the performance of these functions
so we did that
and then the developer for geographics
came and told us that in fact
the improvements have speeded up a
certain example in geographics for a
particular geoprojection piece
and basically this has become something
like 35 times
faster in 12.2 because underneath the
hood it's calling
the ecobee cn so that's a dramatic
improvement for us we are really happy
to see this
happening okay so you do make an
improvement one power system and it goes
and affects
some other part
okay so that's the equivalent function
and why they are important 12.2
but uh when you do calculus them in fact
you have
a layer on top and we have added two
functions
to that layer on top for doing calculus
there are two new functions
jacobi epsilon and yokobi zn
so ecobee epsilon is actually defined to
be the integral
of the square of jacobi dn
tn and the question is why is it
important well
uh this is a canonical form for elliptic
integrals
of the second kind so when you do epic
integer there are three kinds there's
elliptic integral type one
type two and type three and the second
type
can now be described very efficiently
using these ecobee
epsilon functions so that's we're kind
of making a breakthrough
in a small way towards a deeper
understanding of elliptic integrals
in uh mathematica now
on the other hand um we have this jacobi
cn
that requires explanation so we already
had ecobee zeta which is useful for
working with
elliptic functions but the problem with
ecoboost is
that it works with what's called a u
coordinate now when you work with the
electric function you can use u
coordinates of five coordinates
and equivalence later you were using the
phi coordinates that is not so good it's
periodic
but it has branch cuts so in 1997 a user
wrote to us saying that
that's not good you need a function that
works with you and not phi
and he said that in fact if uh carl
ustav yokobi had been alive
he would have turned in his grave at the
thought of you are doing
the wrong thing well uh 23 years later
we have fixed that problem and we now
have jacobi zn which is actually
a metamorphic extension of jacobi zeta
so we have jacob
zeta which is old and yokoba zen which
is new
but they serve slightly different
purposes
so that's one way to use these
jacobi functions to do calculus the
question is
what else can you do with them well what
you can do with them now is to define
new functions
and those are the lame functions from
uh mathematical physics gabriella in the
19th century so we have
a six new lame functions this lame c
with lamin s
and the associate function the
derivatives and the eigenvalues
in 12.2 uh now c stands for roughly sine
uh cosine and s stands for for sine and
the question is why
well here's the differential equation
for lame functions so it's a
differential equation with elliptic
coefficients now these
elliptic functions appear as
coefficients
of differential equations and that's the
corresponding eigenvalues so you're
solving an eigenvalue problem
and you get back lamia s in this case as
a solution
now although they look frighteningly
difficult these lumi functions in fact
have
the trig functions as special cases so
you can boil them down to cosine and
sine
if you work a little bit and that's
because the parameters of the word can
be adjusted
to get you the differential equations
for sine
and cosine so those are the first three
even lame
s function they look almost like the
sine function they pass through
zero okay so the question is why are
they useful well
they are useful because they can use to
solve the helmholtz equation
in so-called stereocone coordinates
that's a kind of elliptic
quantum system which is used quite a lot
so let me functions are new in 12.2 and
that close one more chapter of the
famous book by abramovic and stegen and
really the question might be
suppose i have a special function which
is only defined by differential equation
it doesn't fit into the mathematical
system what do we do
well we have an answer for you and
you've had for quite some time
that's the notion of a holonomic
function and of course you have a
holonomic sequence
then that's a special sequence so we
have differential root
and difference root which have been
around since version
seven actually and they um have been
quite useful
but we'd like to give them a new look
and so in version
12.2 they have new type setting they
look nicer
they have better documentation they're
easier to use and
the better numerical performance etc so
here's a differential equation
you can set up any differential equation
of your choice linear differential
equation with polynomial coefficients
and you can define a differential root
object
you can plot it just like your own
function see a nice type setting over
there
hides all the details but then you can
drill in and actually work out
what the details are so differential
route encodes
all the information required to work
with that special function which you
just defined
yourself with without any kind of effort
okay once you've done that you can
compute the asymptotics
you can work with it inside all kind of
solvers and it's just
one more special function so this
greatly enlarges the scope both for our
special functions and special sequences
so if you go to the
book and you find it i don't have a
function mathematica well you can define
your own okay
so we really hope that this function
will play a much bigger role
in calculus in the near future and
there's a very nice talk by tigran which
is
planned today which i hope you'll
understand attend to actually understand
this whole area
really well okay
so um i now want to calculus
and we have always had this laplace
transform function first in package form
then a system function of version 4.0
and the laplace transform is simply
defined by an integral so that's the
integral
that defines the laplace transform
and the question is what's the
the property of integral well the s over
here is a parameter
and this integral is an analytic
function of s
in a complex half plane so as long as
stay on the right of a certain
vertical line you're just fine so that's
a sawtooth wave
looks pretty messy but it's laplace
transform
is nice and simple and the question is
how do you go back from that formula
over here to the sawtooth
wave and that's the hard problem with
laplace transforms
inverting them so in version 12.2 we
have
the inversion of such transform using
the bromwich contour integral method
that's a famous method the idea is that
if you look at this function
s of s over here and you think of s
being a complex number
it has not just one but infinitely many
singularities so you count them all up
lay them out in a sum and you get back
the original function
that's a hard problem to solve last year
and
we also support for numerical inversion
using numerics
to do uh inverse laplace transforms and
one last thing
we definitely wanted to uh give people
better documentation
so you've done that over here and
actually we have wonderful documentation
of laplace inverse laplace transform in
version
12.2 so i think that
this is a kind of complete refresh for
laplace transforms
and just to give a couple of examples
for the inversion so here
is an example of a function
which you found by laplace transforming
and the question how do you go back well
when you go back
what we do is we analyze all the
singularities over here and there are
lots of them
and we sum them all up in an inactive
sum
if you like it you can activate it or
you can simply work with the inactive
sum
you can plot it and you see you get back
this beautiful
step function over here so
the documentation documentation's got
many more hairy examples for this kind
of inverse laplace transform
but i think this is a major breakthrough
for us because it finally lets us
go beyond the case of rational functions
and the simple
table lookup kind of things and
on the other hand we also have a
numerical inversion
so there's a small community within our
own which
uh talks about numerical conversion
quite a lot and so we have conversion
of laplace transform and mathematica in
12.2 so
here's a function defined purely
numerically the variable t is not
allowed to be a symbol
and you can work out its inverse laplace
round for this function
uh at each point like in 1.3 over here
now
when you cooked up this example we are
quite proud of it because it did not
give an answer in
12.1 symbolically uh well due to all
efforts
it now works symbolically as well so now
you can compare the symbolic and numeric
values
um and you can actually use different
methods you can use method durbin weeks
talbot
um stay fast whatever you like you can
you know have a feast of methods
available to you for your use for the
military inversion
and so here's a plotter function nice
and oscillatory
but now done purely numerically so you
can do symbolic conversion
you can do numeric inversion and
together you have a pretty powerful
implementation of laplace transforms in
version
12.2
okay so let me now go into a traditional
area differential equations
and we'll continue to break through uh
for differential equations in 12.2
we have lots of improvements for exact
solutions of linear non-linear
differential equations
and here is for example the hoin
equation
which we introduced in 12.1 the point
functions
and that's the kind of normal form it is
a missing second derivative first
derivative sorry
and that's the coefficient over here and
we get backgrounds in terms of
horindi so these normal forms hold the
key to solving
the general hoin ods and we have cracked
that problem very nicely using residue
calculus etc
so that's a big achievement and in fact
we have been working so hard on uh
dsob that i believe in some sense
we are now better than maple for a large
benchmark
of problems so and
so we actually have finally come to a
point where we feel that
we've done enough over here we need to
go on to other greener pastures
so two directions will be first of all
moving into uh
the the field of systems of ods for
dynamic systems etc
and we also want to record a course so
when i have a bit of free time after a
month
i'm going to start recording a course on
differential equations to teach everyone
what differential equations are and how
we can work in the system with them
but i'm really pleased with this
achievement it's a lot of hard work
and it's a great landmark for us
okay so um going on to partial
differential equations
uh well um gave a wonderful talk this
morning
a very scholarly talk and i hope you
were there as well
but basically we have lots of
improvements for exact solutions so
here's the heat equation
in genuine cylindrical coordinates you
got r z and t
there's no theta over here but you can
get these beautiful plots of the
heat evolution in time with our
solutions
so i think we come to a point where
really there are cases where the
numerical method
might not actually give us such good
answers
as the symbolic one
okay and uh as um mentioned we have a
monograph in preparation
which will help people learn pds from
our point of view
uh in version 12. just after maybe it's
a big project
hopefully finish it soon but i think
that at some point very soon
you will have your own mini textbook on
pd's inside
the system okay so uh
i think that this is a great improvement
and i think there's an
environment of textbooks that are coming
out for in this area which is
what we're trying to kind of you know
cater to
okay now um a little bit of
asymptotics so um i worked in
asymptotics for a couple of years along
with the team
and a long time ago i worked on a
statistics that is one of my i would say
one of the most successful projects
and i uh did the initial implementation
of probability expectation
in version 8.0 so i know asymptotics i
know probability
uh can i put them together well we've
done that this
summer and we have two new functions
asymptotic probability assembly
expectation
which hopefully have some kind of use
for asymptotic
statistics the study of limiting
distributions
uh which appear in all kinds of
practical applications
so uh you know the uh asymptotes really
began with the
the the publication of you know doctrine
of chances by
uh dimovera in uh
in 1738 and we actually have tried to
give an example over here
which shows that if you have the
binomial normal and you put n equal to
30 let's say and p is sufficient close
to half
then the n g of the moment generating
functions look sufficiently simple
that's a nice intuitive way of
understanding how
the binomials relate to the normal
discriminant so i think this will give a
lot of insight
and it's a nice way to put back
asymptotics and expectations and
probability together
in one frame
okay so that's about the asymptotics
and i'm quite happy that we're having
this development over here uh
so let me uh go on to algebra now
and we have assumptions all that's a big
break because
because we've always wanted them uh
steven wolfram finally convinced
adam that yes put them in and we did so
here's an equation x square equal to a
x is a real number and you see a greater
than zero then of course you get back
two solutions
if you say s less than a less than zero
you get back
no solutions the problem is that when
you talk about solve
the variable x is a global variable so
there's no parameter
and uh variable separation over here so
here's an equation where you got solved
to raise to x equal 8
and in fact if you put assumptions over
here
that's no different from putting them
inside the
system so assumptions are important
solve but they must be used
with some understanding and care but
nonetheless we have this wonderful
option
of assumptions for solve in version 12.2
we also have a lot of optimization
coming in which will be a separate talk
by adam strzebonsky
uh he's a real expert so i'm going to
leave that to him to talk about
later today okay so
just a few things more and uh let's talk
about
linear algebra so i think linear algebra
is probably the most useful part
of our area of mathematica
and i think that uh we have tried to
show it quite nicely
in the recent lineage of mooc which was
released in august 2020. i was quite
pleased with the response to the blog
post
we gained lots of hits to the website
and in fact people are finding
there's just one typo in the whole
course three people found it i'm really
happy i'm not happy with the typo i'm
happy that people found it okay
so uh i'm really happy people actually
studying this course and learning arts
bro here
we have a study group starting out next
uh monday
which uh i hope that some of you will
consider attending
and uh we'll also have lots of new
documentation for
basic matrix functions which has taken a
lot of effort on part of the team
uh in version 12.2 so in algebra is now
being refreshed
and one last area which i think is worth
mentioning over here is polynomial
algebra so this is the kind of the
oldest
part of system where we have you know
absolutely
it's it's the heritage part of it it's
the old part of the mathematician okay
you touch anything over there you might
put yourself in
real trouble okay but we're going back
over there so here's the expand function
expands the polynomial
and uh you know uh we've worked on
improved documentation for around 35
in expand factor etc so these will get
refreshed first
then we'll go on to the big leap of
actually looking at the functionality
itself
but polymer algebra is another area
expanding quite nicely
and just last month i started a project
to actually develop
a course for an introduction to
elementary algebra
which will hopefully come out in the
next year or so so we'll have
differential equations and then after
we're going to have
the algebra course within a year or so
but i think it's important to teach
young children how to do algebra by
by hand by and look at animations do
exercises
type in simple things but they learn the
world from language they learn algebra i
taught algebra many for many
years at middle in high school i know
how hard it is it's much harder than
doing anything else in the world so
this is the project which i really have
in mind for the next
year okay so i think i should really
finish up i'm running out of time
but i just want to announce that our
team is actually um
you know very going very strong and we
have lots of things today
uh this morning i'll give an excellent
talk on symbolic pds
and that's my talk right now uh you
might want to go to
adam talk and operation he is
truly an expert on this area and you
will definitely enjoy it
and listening to his careful
presentation i'll have a meet-up
which i'll coordinate at 1pm do come
long for that
if you like mathematics education and
won't discuss some ideas it's a good
chance to talk
not just listen to people like me and
you know in these talks
to grant will give a talk on functional
properties at
two o'clock that should be a great talk
as well uh he he's worked hard on
first hoin functions 12.1 now la may
holonomic
function properties he'll talk about so
this should be a very good talk where to
get
an overview of what's happening in that
area
and we have not one but two officers
etai will be coordinating those
and that's me and adam will be helping
out with those
uh officers so do come along if you have
any questions if i didn't get to your
question right now in the talk
if you've got some comments to offer to
me i'll be very happy to
offer them okay so you know um i'm i'm
really um
happy with the way things are thanks to
roger thanks to a team
we are very loyal dedicated hard-working
team
we meet every day uh covert has not
stopped us we have worked harder than
ever
and um it's great to see so much spirit
in such difficult times and i thank you
very much of course for
you know uh coming to the talk and do
give me your feedback there's some time
for questions maybe a few minutes at
least
so um you know i'm happy to answer the
question now i'm happy to
answer questions later on but uh and in
fact uh
braden was coordinating kindly offered
to unmute anyone who wants to ask a
question
so maybe it's a good point for me to
stop
uh and take a few questions
um there's just one question which i
notice from michael
uh about an inverse laplace that's a
good question michael a couple of things
one is that
we could have done that and we sh we
probably will in the future uh
one thing is that we really want to
return a kind of
parametric function object because the
the last in
the last argument of inverse laplace
transform is really a parameter
and so you want one thing that's useful
on the whole range so i hope that
we can do that in the future but michael
i think i'll come back to you and find
out what
what's on your mind uh i totally agree
with you i would love to have it
by the way internally uh we are calling
a function called transforms
backtick n inverse laplace transform so
it's there
uh if you can push us enough we'll push
it out into the system
i hope that answers the question any
other questions for me uh
right so john asked about uh
improvements for green functions
um i think i'll come back to john that
john i think
is a good person to do that um unal is
here on the talk i'll ask him to make a
mental note of that
and that's one of my favorite functions
i just haven't had time to go back to it
sure john we'll do that for you in the
near future any other questions do do
type in or
talk whatever we have a couple of
minutes and then i'll stop and
you know but i do appreciate all your
positive response your support of this
old but interesting area so if there any
questions
please go ahead we have a minute or more
and then we stop okay thank you very
much it's 10 30 and i think she'll let
you go
and i really do appreciate all your
effort uh
for the next uh you know release
of the team and users who are actually
keeping us going so thank you very much
i'll stop over here
you